foreign
people I work at a middle school they
often lean back and suck their teeth
it's like they're having a visceral
reaction to the mere mention of those
years and it makes sense Middle School
is a time like no other it's when
significant biological neurological and
emotional changes are happening all at
the same time
so how do middle schoolers respond to
these changes well some might ignore
deodorant but overuse ax body spray you
can find them holding up the walls
during the school dance
and there's usually a desire to be
treated like an adult but they can't
quite let go of their action figures
you might imagine that it looks a little
like this
this was me
in sixth grade and like many middle
school students I was Earnest I was
Goofy and I was just discovering who I
wanted to be
now I had no idea that I'd go on to
teach Middle School they say the grade
levels you teach are most reflective of
your personality so I'm not quite sure
what it says about me that I later went
on to found a middle school for boys
but in all seriousness it didn't take
long as a teacher to realize that my
male students were acting kind of
strange
I remember there was this one year we
were doing a get to know you activity
where students would use old magazines
to create collages representing who they
were
and many of the collages had all the
things that typical middle schoolers
like the outdoors Sports the latest
fashion the hottest shoes you know all
the important stuff
however there were some that were not
exactly what I had in mind
a group of Middle School boys created
these collages that were comical if not
concerning
it was almost as if they had made
templates of who they thought that they
should be
girls in bikinis fast cars professional
wrestlers first person shooter video
games you get the idea one collage
actually had to have had at least 25
different images of Kim Kardashian
and this wasn't an isolated incident
whether it was going down a somewhat
sketchy YouTube rabbit hole or
mindlessly indulging in meme culture
which we know can get really hairy
really fast I was noticing a pattern
with my boys instead of chalking it up
as mindless activities or typical Middle
School Behavior I decided to investigate
I became a mentor for an after school
program called My Brother's Keeper and
in this space we could have more
in-depth conversations
inspired by the 2016 presidential
debates I asked this group of boys an
age-old question
does absolute power corrupt absolutely
students began to discuss amongst
themselves and then I asked now what
would you do if you had this kind of
power and what if it was unchecked
students continue talking and then they
shared out many of them said that they
would use their power for good or even
share it
and as I listened I felt hopeful
realizing that young men could take a
different path
and then I brought the group together
and I just said
does it have to be this way
they're Collective light bulbs lit up
realizing that they could reject this
version of masculinity and at the same
time I too had an aha moment it became
clear to me
that Middle School boys are so
impressionable and so full of potential
but what if I told you those same middle
school boys could lead us to a more just
and Equitable Society by redefining
masculinity
now in the days and weeks that followed
I continued to reflect on this idea what
actually is masculinity
if we reject the gender binary and
affirm people of all genders how does
masculinity fit into that
what are the expectations of masculinity
when it comes to race class and other
social factors
I knew that middle school was fertile
ground for this work
and my reflection led me to identify
three critical skills that middle
schoolers can practice to redefine
masculinity I call them the three C's
the first one
is confidence
the second is communication and the
third is community
now these three C's stand as the pillars
of my school to show people that middle
schoolers can redefine masculinity now
number one confidence is essential to
teach in middle school students are
exploring their identities and they're
more open to abstract thinking
I believe that having a healthy and
balanced confidence allows boys to feel
good about who they are rather than
feeling uncomfortable for trying to be
someone or not
it's different than simply being praised
or rewarded for achievements but rather
rooted in a deep sense of self and so
what my school does is move away from
either or thinking instead of boys
believing that they have to choose
between being smart or athletic poetic
or pragmatic we guide our boys for more
holistic version of masculinity that
includes both and
as Bell Hooks and Olga Silverstein said
we need men who are empathetic and
strong autonomous and connected
responsible to self friends family to
community and capable of understanding
how those responsibilities are
ultimately inseparable
and from a purely academic standpoint we
provide opportunities to teach
confidence through cross-curricular work
and projects that include math science
the humanities art homec Sports to show
them that deep learning and critical
thinking often require an integration of
all of these subjects teaching
confidence allows boys to understand
that there's an entire spectrum of how
they can express themselves
and they can feel good and value the
complexity of their identity and stand
firm in it with confidence
the second C represents communication
now communication is key to counter the
messages that Society tells boys to
constrict their emotions my school
practices a variety of communication
methods both intra personally and
interpersonally now intra personally is
how you communicate with yourself and
enter personally is how you communicate
with others one example of our
intra-personal communication methods is
we'll have students arrive at their
desks at the beginning of the day
they'll close their eyes breathe evenly
for about a minute so they can just
check in with themselves
see how they're doing what they're
thinking how they're feeling and it
allows them to put a frame around their
thoughts and emotions so they can focus
on a little more deeply throughout the
day
students also keep gratitude journals
research shows that when students
Express gratitude on a regular basis it
increases positive emotions toward
themselves and toward others an
interpersonal practice that we like to
do is at the end of the day we'll have
students gather in a circle to offer an
appreciation for someone or something
open it up to an apology or talk about a
social issue that might be on their
hearts and we normalize these forms of
communication to show boys that it is
perfectly human to open your minds and
your hearts to your community
now the third C represents community
to counter this false sense of
individualism and having to pull
yourself up by your bootstraps while we
also know that there's Great Value in
teaching our boys the importance of
Independence it can be stymied when
taken to an extreme
and so what we do is we engage in an
inquiry process where we observe what's
going on in our communities either
locally nationally or globally and then
pose an essential question
one year we posed an essential question
to our students that asked how can we
create a community where everyone feels
a sense of belonging
students took this question they
generated initial thoughts they sought
multiple perspectives from their peers
their teachers Community leaders and
then they came back to us and said we'd
like to address homelessness in Seattle
we love this idea and so we partnered
with a local construction company to
design build and donate a tiny house
now what we realized is through this
community learning process students felt
the greater sense of satisfaction with
studying taking academic risks and just
valuing the overall learning process in
addition students felt more comfortable
taking on leadership roles inside and
outside of the classroom one thing to
note that in each of these three C's the
adults involved modeled this new version
of masculinity to prove to students that
they don't have to fit into a stereotype
and while I'm often impressed by the
vulnerability and kindness of each of my
students it's still a middle school
it's this liminal space between
childhood and adulthood and amongst our
sophisticated conversations there's a
lot of nonsensical humor
and very few of them have taken up
regular usage of deodorant
and I know that this is lifelong work
and there's no quick fix but they show
me that a better future is possible what
if masculinity meant having a healthy
and balanced confidence communicating
clearly being connected to your
community
just imagine how different our world
would be my students don't even show me
that this future is possible but this
future is here with Middle School boys
leading the way
thank you
foreign